to do things in the world if you want to  do business you want a business partner  if you want to build a family you want  another kind of partner you just want to  live outside you need another kind of  partner  you need Partners to act in the world  you don't need Partners to be because  you are the only creature on the planet  who is being referred to as a being  sparrows are flying around you can't fly  but we don't call them bird beings  they're just Birds tiger is roaming in  the forest We Don't Call Him a tiger  being an elephant is Raging through the  forest we don't call him an elephant  being only this one we're calling a  being because this one is supposed to  know how to be